in the earlier video on DNA replication
we go into some detail about leading
strands and lagging strands and all of
the different actors all of these
different enzymatic actors but I left
out what is probably the most
mind-boggling aspect of all of this and
that's the speed and the precision with
which this is actually happening as we
talked about in that video
it feels pretty complex you have this
topoisomerase that's that's unwinding
things the helicase is unzipping it then
you have the polymerase it can only go
from the 5 prime to 3 prime direction
and needs a little primer to get started
but then it starts adding the it starts
adding the nucleotides on the lagging
strand you have to have the art you get
the RNA primer but then it's going in
it's going from once again from 5 prime
to 3 prime so you have these Okazaki
fragments and all of this craziness
that's happening and remember these
things don't have brains these aren't
computers they don't know exactly where
to go it's all because of the chemistry
they're all bumping with the into each
other and reacting in just the right way
to make this incredible thing happen now
what I'm about to tell you is really
going to boggle your mind because this
is happening incredibly fast DNA
polymerase has been clocked at least in
e.coli has a clocked at approaching
1,000 base pairs per second I think the
number that I saw was 700 something base
pairs per second so polymerase let me
write this down this is worth writing
down because it's mind-boggling it gives
you a sense of just how amazing what you
do the machinery in your cells are so
it's been as high as and it can change
it can speed up and slow down and that's
actually been observed but polymerase as
fast as as fast as 700 plus base pairs
per per second so if this on this
diagram and it's just zipping it's just
zipping along at least from our
perceptual frame of reference so the
second seems like a very short amount of
time to us but at a molecular scale
these things are just bouncing around
and just getting this stuff done now the
second thing that you might be wondering
okay this is happening fast but surely
there it has
lot of errors well the first thing you
might say well if I had a lot of errors
that would really not be good for
biology because you always have you have
DNA replicating and all throughout our
lives and at some point you just have so
many errors that the cells wouldn't
function anymore and so lucky for us
that this is actually a fairly precise
process even in the first pass of the
polymerase you have one mistake you have
one mistake let me write this down
because it's amazing
one mistake for every for every
approximately ten to the seventh so this
is ten million ten million in
nucleotides nucleotides and that might
seem pretty accurate but you got it we
gotta remember we have we have billions
of nucleotides in our DNA so this would
still introduce a lot of errors but then
there is proofreading that goes back and
make sure that those errors aren't don't
stick around and so once all the
proofreading takes place it actually
becomes one mistake one mistake for
every approximately 10 to the ninth
nucleotides so approximately you can you
can do this in an incredibly fast pace
as fast as 700 plus approaching 1,000
base pairs per second and you have one
error every billion nucleotides
especially after you go through these
proofreading steps and so it's
incredibly fast and it's incredibly
precise so hopefully that gives you a
better appreciation for just the magic
that's literally I mean look at your
hand or just think about this is
happening in in all of the cells or most
of the cells of your body as we speak